I'm Olivia, I'm 17, and I live in Greenwich, Connecticut.
My favorite things in the world are swimming and science.
My family loves science too.
That's probably where I get it from.
My teacher encouraged us to watch the news and see what was going on in the world.
That's how I became intrigued with the Ebola crisis.
Over 11,000 people died during the 2014 outbreak, which is shocking.
I wanted to help and thought there must be a faster way to diagnose the virus...
...before an outbreak like this grew into an epidemic.
So, my goal was to create a simple, inexpensive diagnostic device for Ebola...
...and transport it without refrigeration.
The results of my experiment were really successful.
I developed the Ebola Assay Card,...
...a device that changes color when the virus has been detected.
It requires no refrigeration for transportation...
...and can confirm in under 30 minutes if someone is infected.
I think imagination and optimism are important parts of innovation.
Teenagers have that, and so they try things that maybe adults think will fail.
One day, I hope to become a doctor and see firsthand how I can make a difference.
And maybe now, I'm one step closer.